welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition summer's almost
here and it's about to get hotter than
Charlotte Hale with the penultimate
episode of Westworld season three now
out worldwide throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
latest entry and giving our thoughts on
what's gonna be happening in the finale
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out episode 7 yet and don't want
anything ruined then I highly recommend
that you turn off now make sure you
subscribe to the channel because we do
fan theories and breakdowns on it week
by week and you don't want to miss any
of the updates without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of Westworld season 3 episode
7 ok so the episode past porn of course
refers to Caleb it's one of the simplest
titles thus far and it very much refers
to how in the episode he basically
becomes a pawn that's passed from
machine to machine initially he was
under Rehoboth control and then he came
to be used by Dolores before being
passed to Solomon it's clear that though
this episode gives him some agency he
doesn't have much power in the grand
scheme of things and still remains a
pawn I think it could also be a play on
the word past as in the past and it
could be hinting that Caleb used to be a
pawn in the army / Rico app but it could
also mean that he is finally broken free
and that when all of this is done he
will be moving of his own accord caleb
has very much been this season's Dolores
as he was joined by companion that was
quote-unquote free much in the same way
that she was with William and together
on their mission he's learned about his
true nature and managed to escape from
it
that's just how I took it but we'll
discuss it more in this video as we get
into it the episode opens with Rehoboam
and complete meltdown and the world is
very much sort of all over the place I
think that 50% of the planet is probably
having a great time and enjoying the
fact that they have a bright future
ahead of them if Robin is right and the
others aren't looking forward to what
could lie in store this was very much
reflected in last week's episode in
which we heard of some staff at inner
journeys complaining that some of
left and they had to pick up the slack
the fact that these guys stayed it
probably means that they got lucky with
their future and we see that in
Indonesia people are still enjoying the
pubs and clubs like there's no lockdown
here we see Musashi who as we know is
Delores and he sends a briefcase off to
one of his friends we don't know who
this could be but it does leave a lot of
things up in the air I did see people on
reddit saying the thing that this may be
the fit Delores pearl but I'm sure that
that was actually just Bernard
I think this may have been a special
delivery that she received in episode 5
but I'm not 100% there was also said to
be another ally in Berlin so we could
have one last Delores reveal in store
anyway Musashi gets a message from her
Loras who looks like she's been sat in
the makeup chair at boots for the last
week great job now this could be a
hologram as we do see one appear in the
preview for next week and it would
explain how she's no longer burnt it
does look like she has turned to serac
who may have provided her with the
ability to fix herself he did want to
take her in alive in the previous
episode and she was clearly angered by
Dolores zooming them all and Mae went
rogue she definitely didn't return to
Arnold's house and fix herself as serac
had that under control but yeah there's
a lot of questions over how she's
returned like this maybe she just used
the healing pen on herself but make sure
you drop your theories below either way
she's given the location to Maeve who
has given it to her best buddy
Clementine there's an awesome shootout
and we get the return of another host
Hannah yarrow
she stabs some Shashi and they take him
for his pearl which reflects how he was
going to take Maeve's
so yeah a lot to unpack from this
opening but I think overall we can take
from it that Hale is now in league with
serac after the credits we are treated
to Caleb staying I'm Caleb Nichols and
it sounds very much like he's just
running through a script he gets flashes
of Francis who's wound he held similarly
to liam Dempsey juniors this is at the
re-education Center which becomes
central to him discovering his past
we then see Caleb and Dolores trotting
across some land in Mexico on horseback
this land was actually replicated in
West world and Caleb is clearly figured
out that she's a host from the uprising
Dolores states that she wishes to use
him as a leader for Humanity a messiah
but I don't think that she would give
humanity
that much control instead we can look at
it in a different way and thank you to
Dax L Kurtz on reddit for providing this
so the use of state of that Dolores
wants to make a place for our people on
earth which Rehoboam currently runs
therefore it needs to be destroyed as it
is a human problem
it needs a human solution so Dolores has
created a narrative for a human ie Caleb
in which he becomes the Messiah however
that would make her just as bad as
fought in serac and she would have to
deny that person freewill so instead she
found someone who had already been given
a loop and she is simply making them
aware of everything that so that they
will create an uprising of their own
accord she pretty much influences him
throughout this conversation and he goes
from just being a construction worker
they're getting the idea planted in his
mind that he's something more we get
more flashbacks including his mission in
chimera in which he was hunting down
insurgents these flashbacks are laced
with a female doctor guiding him and she
tells him to start at the beginning this
is a callback to season one in which
Dolores was to told this when she had
problems with her memories I love this
scene and also like the high-tech
surveillance that sent it around just
donning glasses in order to confirm a
target and then watching a satellite
strike take them down Caleb and ko were
then tracked by insurgents themselves
and heavily damaged during the attack
they were honorably discharged after
this and it was wiped from their
memories and then melded into a
brand-new branching storyline that would
hide their true mission which we'll get
into in just a bit according to that
story line at caleb and francis ended up
capturing the insurgent leader
themselves which led to the man in the
chair that we've seen later throughout
his memories however this was all a ruse
and a planned carried out in the
re-education Center to hide the truth it
turns out that in the end saw Rock's
plan was to use outliers to take out
outliers and with the Rico app they were
able to regulate crime it's revealed
that Francis and Caleb were hired by the
app to take out a man named Whitman he
was part of the pharmaceutical company
that created the limbic tablets and
after asking one too many questions he
was identified as an outlier after
capturing him Caleb ended up listening
to what he had to say and when he told
them too much they were given alerts to
kill one another in exchange for a
reward France
likely knew of this before Caleb but he
didn't wish to do it and Whitman divulge
to Caleb what normally happened in such
circumstances which gave him a heads up
on the preceding predicament
Caleb ended up killing Francis before he
could kill him and this is why Dempsey
jr. said you did it in the present
Dolores and Caleb arrived re-education
Center in the middle of the desert and
using an incredibly high-tech sniper
rifle and drunk combination she takes
out all the gods there this is one of
the things that was in the bag that got
a special delivery for but there are
other elements to it and the pieces of
it could be used to rebuild the Loris in
the next episode
inside caleb takes a very similar stroll
through it - what liam Dempsey senior
did when meeting with serac and he
begins to piece together what happened
to him
he was one of the first to receive
treatment and though it was effective
journeying with Dolores has opened his
eyes to what's going on their main
objective is to find Solomon the prior
version of Rehoboam and it's not too
long before they come across it it
actually has the voice of John me by
default and it's classified as being
schizophrenic which of course is very
similar to Caleb's mother it doesn't
seem like the caleb is surak's brother
theory is true but yeah I did quite like
these parallels Solomon actually has
difficulty deciphering whether it's the
present or whether this is a simulation
or not and it's nice that machines
similar to humans do tackle with their
reality and having self-awareness
maybe William should hang out with it
anyway inside the facility they come
across a message for John me left by
serac looking at it in the mind state
that serac is no longer alive it does
make a lot of sense his hair is gray and
yet we have seen in the flashbacks that
it was brown and it's only in the more
recent times that it turned this shade
so it is possible that this was recorded
a while back and at some point Rehoboam
ended up taking his form and then using
it through a hologram he convinced the
world he was still alive the line I wish
I could be there with you John me but
the man I was and no longer exists seems
to tease at this and it does look like
the serac is a hologram theory could be
coming true hey I have to hold on to
something after a couple of my theories
turned out to be untrue right and by a
couple I mean every single one of them
hashtag Bernard is still the key I have
to believe they discover all the
outliers that were taken out the system
including John me they
actions that sir Akron did not fit the
data and thus the data had to change
which is why so many were removed
there were parallels here of the hosts
that were kept in storage in the park
and it's here that the big reveal about
Caleb comes to the surface may have
arrived shortly after and Dolores makes
Solomon create a new strategy that will
allow Caleb to create a revolution with
humanity
I love how Solomon says if you die I
will adjust my projections and the two
go head-to-head in one of the best
action scenes in the season so far
Maeve has become a traitor to her kind
in a way and it's nice that she's been
forced to flip roles so Rach ended up
killing a man earlier in the season that
gave Dolores information and he called
him a traitor to his kind
so this mirroring here is a good
callback that shows their opposing
ideologies Dolores gets her on blown off
and it's a real tense moment as she
flees from Maeve who goes after her with
a samurai sword
using the EMP that was placed as a
countermeasure for Solomon Dolores
deactivates both itself and Maeve
leading to their fates being up in the
air Solomon also tried to give Caleb a
warning but this was unable to be
delivered now of course they aren't dead
and even though they were taken out by
emps that pills are intact it's just
their systems that are disabled so they
will be able to come back because well
no points for guessing that they're
needed for the finale the other story
line that is laced throughout the
episode centers around Bernard Stubbs
and William Williams awakening from last
week gave him a purpose and we learn
this episode it's to basically destroy
the hosts nice nice one glad glad we
learned something this is to right the
wrong of his original sin and therefore
and do the one thing that led to all of
this misery it turns out that Hale also
injected William with a virus that
hacked at AI system and provided the
tracking data that allowed Bernard and
sips to find him it's also wiped William
from the system and declared him is dead
this could also be a byproduct of the
re-education Center and perhaps Iraq
declares those that enter it dead so
that it can provide them with a new
identity in order to stop William taking
back Delos he probably also needs him
off the board so this all ties together
neatly into his plan Ciroc has been
trying to reprogram people and William
sell him the data in destroying house
this will right his wrongs and I love
how he threatens Bernard and Stubbs with
death
should they not kill him first also an
interesting detail that insider.com
pointed out was that William and Caleb
actually have the same ID number how
this will play out we don't quite know
yet but they are linked in some way
perhaps Hale changed his ID number to
Williams to flag him up on the system so
that Caleb and Dolores could move
undetected but that we don't have a
solid answer yet I have no idea why
these are the same but it does seem
interesting that they could be linked
and they have had the old switcheroo
done at the re-education Center in order
to cover one and to expose the other we
know that William is a crucial part to
gaining access to the board at Delos so
maybe it was given to Caleb so that he
could bypass it again I don't know
what's happening please let me know in
the comments below they go to a gas
station with a sign that says from lab
to slab which is a callback to Bernards
job recreating meet William manages to
get shotgun and he holds the gun to the
pair leaving their fate also up in the
air
Caleb finds Dolores his body and he's
then told that he has some instructions
by an AI voice once more showing that
this past porn has been given another
master as for the finale
riots are spilling over into the street
and we are told that this is indeed the
prediction that Robin made that
prophesized the end of the world Dolores
is rebuilt and Hale returns as a
hologram likely under the control of
Ciroc Maebh is going back against
Dolores and it seems like caleb is
plugged in to Rehoboam himself perhaps
to pass over the doomsday strategy that
he was given so that it can enact
countermeasures either way I'm so hyped
for the finale but I'm good that it's
almost over
this episode wasn't too laced with
Easter eggs but it's been an incredible
ride and I can't wait to see what
happens next
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode and what you're
expecting in the finale comment below
and let us know and if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a thumbs up and
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the series so far we've gone through
each episode week by week and also
discussed some of the craziest theories
that you might have heard on the show if
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below every
month we give away free move
two people are subscribed to the channel
and this month he can win the Marvel
phase 3 part 1 box set and all you have
to do is comment on a video and make
sure you sub with notifications on for
more videos you comment on the more you
have a chance of winning so make sure
you get involved the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of May so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you